Kentucky Republican senator that's Rand
Paul joins us now from Capitol Hill he's
a member of the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee and he supported President
Trump's decision to meet with Vladimir
Putin
Senator Paul long time no see very good
to see you this morning thank you thank
you for joining us listen you've heard
the avalanche of criticism and
negativity appalling shameful
disgraceful shocking it's coming from
all sides and I'm wondering you're here
this morning are you doing out clean up
on aisle three well you know I think we
ought to take a step back and look at
the bigger picture and decide whether or
not we want to have conversations with
even our adversaries turn the height of
the Cold War during the Cuban Missile
Crisis kennedy had a direct line to
Khrushchev and I think the world is a
safer and a much better place because we
had that line of communication we had a
bastard well let me finish my question
we're gonna ask questions let me finish
all right all right it was also it was
also I think a good idea that we've
continued to have ambassadors and
diplomatic relations with Russia even
though they are our adversaries senator
ball I don't think anybody would object
to trying to have a good relationship
with Russia I think the problem is that
he seemed to throw the American
intelligence community under the bus
while doing that is there I think that's
incorrect I think what you just said
that no one would object to him meeting
with Putin every Democrat on Capitol
Hill objected to him meeting with Putin
every and neoconservative and war monger
on the right also objected to it so yes
the vast majority of the foreign policy
community the bipartisan consensus said
you shouldn't meet with Putin
they also said he shouldn't meet with
Kim and this is an extraordinary thing
about President Trump that should be
lauded and not belittled is that he is
willing to meet with adversaries to try
to prevent us from having World War
three but you talked about the Cold War
history and one of the things that was
distinct about both President Kennedy
you mentioned and President Reagan was
that they did two things they both met
with America's adversaries and they were
quite clear about America's moral view
about the repression of both the Soviet
Union and then subsequent to that Russia
now which most people think is led by
basically a dictator what the president
didn't do and he's getting criticized
for is he did not make that moral case
he basically said in the relationship
between the two both sides are at fault
that
the distinction here not the weather to
have my meeting so what about that I
don't think you yeah but but I don't
think you're being fair of the president
so when President Reagan met with
Gorbachev do you think he listed the
litany of Soviet abuses from Stalin on
in a one-to-one meeting no they were
listed and recounted by other people in
the administration there have also been
people within the Trump administration
have listed and recounted the human
rights violations in Russia but we also
have to understand that we have to deal
with the world as it is not as we wish
it to be and if we're only going to talk
to people who have perfect
constitutional republics we're gonna
have a very small audience and we're
gonna have a lot of potential conflict
with no outlet for diplomacy so no I
think the president did a good thing by
meeting with Putin and I think it's a
mistake for people to sort of try to try
to turn this into a partisan partisan
escapade Senate President Reagan called
the Soviet Union the evil empire many of
his most famous comments are calling out
the Soviet Union on its moral
shortcomings so I think that comparison
between President Reagan President Trump
is is off a bit but let me ask you this
question and he's also been a tradition
of that I'll respond to that I'll say
Reagan also sat down Gorbachev and
didn't call it an evil empire in a press
conference with Gorbachev he also sat
down with Gorbachev and we also had
strategic arms limitations so they
actually did while the rhetoric was
strong you actually might compare that
to Trump's rhetoric with North Korea
it's been very strong but he's been
willing to sit down with it so I think
there's actually some apt comparisons
between the diplomatic front the
difference here is Senator the president
Trump is not short about offering
criticism to American allies whether
it's on the German gas deal or whether
immigration is destroying Europe but
when it comes to Russia he seems to have
in all instances whether he's standing
next to the Russian president or just
quietly by himself in a one-on-one
interview bends over backwards to say
nice things about the Russians and that
that Rob's him of an opportunity to make
a clear moral case about the distinction
between America which has grown up and
had a history of supporting freedom and
the Russian regime which does not know
so and why not take that opportunity as
an American president I think what this
gets into is that the president has
undergone an onslaught of a year year
and a half of a partisan investigate
and accusing him of somehow colluding
with the Russian so I think he's
sensitive to that but there's another
aspect to the investigation that is the
legitimate one and that is saying did
Russians hack Hillary Clinton's emails
and so there's a legitimate aspect and
then there's a partisan aspect and we
all have now concluded and all
understand that the investigation was
started by partisans James clapper John
Brennan who started the investigation at
the behest of the Clinton campaign who
paid somebody in Russia to come up with
a dossier so really it's funny that we
keep helmet Trump in Russia when in fact
the only person actually known to pay
Russian agents was Hillary Clinton who
paid a British spy who then paid British
agents for turned-on concocted dirt on
Trump I know we can go down that road
again but I still think the question
remains does he have to throw the
American intelligence community under
the bus I still think that's a big
questions but we're gonna have to leave
it there some of the reasons for it one
of the reasons for is James clapper is a
known liar is lied to Congress so
someone who's for transparency senator a
lot of people were outraged at this that
meeting took place privately I think
that was a lot of concern as well but
we're gonna have to leave it there we
appreciate you joining us thank you